Here the solution to our equation is 2. Great work if you got that one orrect.
Now if you didn't quite know how to handle this four let's see how to do it,
then you can pause the video once you figure out and then continue solving. To
start we'll square both sides of the equation so we can undo the square root.
We square 4 which equals 16, and then we square the radical which gives us the
x minus 1. Just this radicant. On the right side we square the binomial 8 minus
2x. This gives us this polynomial. We'll distribute the 16 on the left side of
the equation to get 16x minus 16. On the right-hand side, I'll just re-arrange
the position of these two terms so I have my x squared term first. We'll have
4x squared, since it's positive, negative 32x, and positive 64, or plus 64.
Next we want to set our equation equal to 0, so we subtract 16x from both
sides. And we add 16 to both sides. We do this since we know we'll get 0 on the
left, and this polynomial on the right. We'll have a quadratic that we can try
and factor. All of these terms have a common factor of four, so we can divide
out our equation by that factor. We'll have 0 equals x squared minus 12x plus
20. Next, we find factors of positive 20 that sum to negative 12. These factors
are negative 10, and negative two. We set each factor equal to 0, so x can
equal 10 or x can equal 2. And finally, we check x equals 10, and x equals 2,
and the original equation. When we do this, we see that 10 does not check, we
get 12 equal to negative 12. So this one is not going to be part of our
solution set. However, for 2, it does check, so this must be our only solution.
So don't worry if you stumbled at the beginning with squaring this 4, if you
are able to finish it out, great work.